bien estamos en el problema número 7 el
problema número 7 y me dice lo siguiente
si x vale un medio si x vale un medio
entonces cuando vale 1 entre x más 1
entre x menos 1 bueno lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que si x
vale un medio
cuanto vale x menos 1 x menos 1 es lo
mismo que un medio menos 1 y esto lo
mismo que menos un medio ok entonces si
sustituimos en esta expresión aquí esto
es exactamente lo mismo que tener uno
entre x pero extra de un médium uno
entre un medio más uno entre x menos uno
pero x menos uno vale menos un medio
entre menos un medio y bueno aquí hay
dos formas de resolver esto de una
manera muy rápida
la primera es resolviendo esta expresión
que tengo aquí y las segundas dándote
cuenta que esto se va a cancelar se
quiten un menos entonces éste lo puedo
quitar de aquí y poner aquí un menos y
este volverlo positivo
esto pues es claramente 0 o la otra
forma es que tú evalúe si digas 1 entre
un medio pues esto es 2 - 1 entre un
medio lo cual es 2 y 2 - 2 es cero así
que éste estaba muy fácil este es un
problema de velocidad a ver qué tan
rápido puedes hacerlo y cuánto tiempo
tarda en resolverlo así que no hay más
que ser en este problema vamos a ver el
siguiente problema el problema número 8
déjenme borrar la pantalla y el problema
número 8 tienen un plano cartesiano así
que vamos a hacerlo por aquí tengo a mi
eje james por acá tengo a mi eje x
perfecto vamos a poner que este este de
aquí
déjenme cambiar de color este de aquí es
el eje james este de aquí es el eje x
por aquí me dicen que este es el punto
1,0 1,0 y después tengo
tengo los siguientes fíjate bien tengo
un par es un cuadrado que toca un punto
aquí aquí tengo un punto sube esto por
acá o algo así y después tengo algo por
acá parecido a esto y qué datos me dan
bueno me dan en este punto este punto se
llama r
después me dan este punto este punto se
llama s
llama t
después me dicen que este es un ángulo
recto este también es un ángulo recto y
además me dicen que esta medida que la
medida de rs está de aquí
es exactamente la misma que la medida de
ese tema es decir esta de aquí y si
estas dos medidas son iguales y este es
un ángulo recto y este es un ángulo
recto
este es un cuadrado este de aquí es un
cuadrado muy bien y después me dicen que
ese es entidad como coordenadas el punto
cam
de este titán como coordenadas el punto
que tres y lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale que yo lo que quiero saber es el
valor de cam pero esto está muy sencillo
porque este de aquí
acabamos de concluir que es un cuadrado
porque esta longitud y esta longitud es
la misma este ángulo y este ángulo son
iguales y son ángulos rectos y por lo
tanto esto también es un ángulo recto
este mes un ángulo recto y todos los
lados vienen lo mismo ahora si este
punto tiene como coordenadas que tres
eso quiere decir que aquí donde corta al
gel hay ese es el valor de tres o dicho
otra manera que la distancia que hay
aquí hasta acá esta distancia es 3 ahora
los padres que si esta distancia es 3 si
esta distancia es 3 entonces como es un
cuadrado estas distancias 3 esta
distancia es 3 y ésta también va a ser 3
perfecto todos los lados miden 3 pero si
yo lo que quiero saber es el valor de
acá hay que tener cuidado porque lo que
estamos haciendo es moviendo unos 3
hacia la izquierda después del cero
estamos retrocediendo 3 y para
retroceder de 3 nos iríamos menos 1 - 2
- 3 y ya está si yo lo que quiero saber
es el valor de x de este punto de aquí
pues el valor de x de este punto de aquí
es menos 3,3 que es por cierto el valor
de ca la distancia de aquí acá son tres
unidades eso es importante pero hay que
tener en cuenta que como estamos del
lado izquierdo del origen entonces en
este punto tiene como coordenadas menos
33 que es igual a menos 3 este también
estaba bastante fácil hay que tener
cuidado si estás después del origen o
antes del origen para sacar los valores
de equis y de jeff muy bien pues vamos a
resolver el siguiente problema el
problema número 9 el problema número 9
que tiene una tabla así que vamos a
hacer la tabla con otro color tengo algo
así
así es una tabla pequeña dice x y aquí
tengo a efe x y xv a de 0 1 2 3 mientras
que fx va 12 5 y 10 perfecto ahora dice
la tabla de a continuación esta tabla
muestra los valores de una función
cuadrática fx es una función cuadrática
esto es importante
efe de x es una función cuadrática
práctica práctica ok
cuando los siguientes incisos
representan a ft x de hecho lo que me
piden es cuánto vale efe de x
eso es lo que yo quisiera saber ahora
cómo podemos resolver esto fx es una
función cuadrática y todas las funciones
cuadráticas se ven de la forma a x
cuadrada más b x +
esto es una función cuadrática y de aquí
de una manera muy fácil podemos concluir
cuánto vale c porque cuánto vale efe de
bueno pues efe de 0 es lo mismo qué
a x 0 + b por 0 más
estos dos se van y me queda solamente se
y esto por otra parte me dicen que f de
cero es uno por lo tanto de aquí puedo
concluir que se vale 1
es decir que esta ecuación cuadrática se
ve más o menos de este estilo
f x es igual a x cuadrada más b x más 1
al menos ya sabemos el valor de c
pero bueno aquí se me ocurre que
podremos hacer un sistema de ecuaciones
y eso lo veo bastante difícil creo que
es bastante complicado esto vamos a
pensar debe de ser mucho más fácil
porque recuerda que los ejercicios del s
artes son ejercicios pensados para que
se resuelva en el menor tiempo posible
de una manera muy rápida si yo sustituyó
aquí el valor de 1 después del valor de
2 y después el valor de 3 voy a
encontrar un sistema de ecuaciones y no
creo que eso sea lo mejor
por cierto es un sistema de ecuaciones
para y para ver pero vamos a pensar un
poco el cero me lo manda al 1 el 1 me lo
manda al 2 el 1 me lo manda al 2 es
decir que estoy elevando al cuadrado al
1 porque es una función cuadrática y le
estoy sumando 11 más 1 es 2 a ver al 2
lo voy a elevar al cuadrado 44 más uno
es 5 al 3 le llegó al cuadrado es 9 más
uno es 10 y creo que ya quedó si
nosotros somos un poco de lógica y nos
fijamos también los incisos nos vamos a
dar cuenta que si fx si fx de pura
casualidad fuera x cuadrada más 1 es
decir el valor de ese 7 x fuera en que
es cuadrada más 1
creo que este es mi candidato que va a
funcionar para hacer la función
cuadrática de esta tabla y vamos a
comprobarlo pero al cuadrado más uno es
perfecto esto funciona 1 al cuadrado más
1 esto es 2 también funciona a 2 al
cuadrado 2 a cuadrados 4 1 y 5 también
funciona y 3 al cuadrado más 1 es 10
perfecto también funciona es decir que
esta es la representación completa de mi
función cuadrática efe de x aquí está de
una manera explícita cuánto vale efe
x y recuerda que todos estos problemas
están pensados para que los resuelva de
una manera muy rápida si te queda algo
muy complicado no creo que sea la mejor
opción aquí si nosotros evaluamos el
valor de uno el valor de dos y el valor
de tres pensando en que este es un
modelo infalible para encontrar el
resultado claro que vamos a llegar el
resultado pero utilizando un sistema de
ecuaciones lo cual parece ser bastante
tardado sin embargo si nosotros nos
fijamos y usamos un poco de lógica para
ver cuál podría ser nuestra solución nos
podemos dar cuenta de una manera mucho
más sencilla utilizando la intuición y
la lógica de no
la respuesta que en este caso es esta de
aquí lo padre de los problemas de ese
tema es que tienen ecuaciones muy
sencillas así que no es tan difícil a
veces probar todos nuestros sencillos
para ver cuál es el que realmente
funciona que en este caso puede ser una
buena forma de resolver este problema en
fin vamos a hacer el problema número 10
para terminar este vídeo el problema
número 10 que me dice lo siguiente ahora
bien que si no quedó muy claro el el
problema pasado
escríbeme para saber que no te quedó
claro el problema pasado porque si
realmente lo hago de la otra forma del
sistema de ecuaciones y va a ser eterno
así que utilizando la filosofía de los
problemas del stm creo que fue mucho más
fácil resolverlo de esa manera en fin
problema número 10 qué edad tenía hace
un año una persona que exactamente hace
equis años tenía 10 años
este es el típico problema que pueden
confundirte es más déjeme leerle otra
vez qué edad tenía hace un año lo que
queremos saber es la edad que tiene no
actualmente sino la edad que tenía hace
un año una persona que exactamente hace
equis años tenía 10 años como resuelvo
esto se me ocurre poner aquí la edad
actual y va a ser la edad actual la edad
actual y qué me dicen de la edad actual
bueno que exactamente hace equis años
tenía 10 años es decir que sea la edad
actual le quitamos x años a la edad
actual le voy a quitar x años pues esto
me dan 10 años hace x años en un tiempo
anterior en x años tenía esa persona y
años o dicho otra manera la edad actual
es igual a ye
x actualmente tiene ya más x años ye más
x años pero no queremos saber la edad
actual lo que queremos saber es qué edad
tenía hace un año es decir la edad
actual menos un año esto lo queremos ir
preguntando qué edad tenía esta persona
hace un año y no te confundas ya tengo
esto pues lo puedo sustituir por acá es
decir que la edad que tenía hace un año
es x más
- 1 esta es mi respuesta que por cierto
es el inciso en y bueno ya no tengo
tiempo para hacer otro problema pero
este creo que estuvo fácil estar un poco
confuso y si tuviste problemas con el
problema pasado entonces házmelo saber
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo